[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
careful boys with the most careful of
the boys we got with us today christian
hey
i'm a little dangerous guy oh he's a
danger guy
he's a danger boy wait what is careful
boys well we have to be careful these
days because it's a different era
you know everyone's getting canceled you
know yeah we everyone's more sensitive
and we've grown and matured so that's
why we got to be careful boys can't say
the same [ __ ] anymore because people try
to hold you accountable for [ __ ] like
what like give us an example for them
being for them having asperger's what
would you have said like five years ago
that you can't say now dude on my
instagram my instagram got [ __ ]
demonetized like six times
dude and then look i just got i just got
[ __ ] flagged again why dude and i
have to love you too luckily i know
someone in there they didn't like when
they're watching when you're watching
coachella from the living room with your
with taika
look at this look at how many [ __ ]
violations i have dude i i got in
trouble for inciting violence
on the article on the article on there
was a pic there's a video of this famous
youtuber mma youtuber named mma shredded
right yeah and he did a video with alex
okay his name mma shredded his name jeff
chan yup
alex is doing a video with him
and he's doing an intro saying hey i'm
here with jason chen my boy jason chan
yeah yeah and points to jeff chan right
so then i commented i said hey
mma shredding it's just constant beeping
i can't i can't reset the timer it's
[ __ ] it up
there we go
i'm trying to change the channel on this
boring ass story
should we restart again it sounds like
we're in a hospital bro jesus christ the
professionalism is amazing that guy just
like on a heart monitor all right so
alex introduced jeff chan as jason chen
and then what happened why why because
he just it was racist he was just racist
was it was it just it was a slip it was
just a slip up i thought we were doing
to be funny no no i literally was just
like he really meant jason chan okay the
singer okay so that i commented and and
uh
jeff chan reposted it on his instagram
so i commented and i said you should
have punched lift god in the face that's
his at on instagram and then i got
[ __ ] i got my [ __ ] deactivated for
like a whole week yeah bro because i
said it was inciting violence i mean you
are i don't want to get punished but you
should have got punches
you can't uh you can't say anything with
violent words
you can't talk [ __ ] about other people
and you can't even talk [ __ ] about
yourself someone was asking like oh it's
like a good podcast whatever listen to
it i was like oh yeah listen to jk news
it's like the lowest iq debate you'll
ever see and then boom that that that
comment gets taken self-deprecate
you can't say [ __ ] you can't make no
jokes yeah i got my [ __ ] taken down
because um this guy was like joe
how do you get such big arms now like i
beat my girlfriend
that's a good joke that's a good joke
there's actually this uh there's this
playboy cardi song called stop breathing
and like it's always in the comments of
like random post going what's your
favorite cardi song and whenever someone
comments stop breathing they get banned
from instagram because instagram thinks
it says stop breathing like you're
trying to incite something
instagram is so dumb like what if you
put it in quotes
yo stop breathing yeah yeah yeah what do
you think what if we wrote
hypothetically speaking first
hypothetically speaking allegedly
yeah we gotta hit allegedly
let's see if that works did you see you
guys are like on the watch list right
now for saying anything
i didn't know either on instagram
they told me this guy for sure is on a
watch yeah he's a wild card he goes on
random people's uh instagrams like like
fighters and stuff and i'll scroll
through and i just see a little check
mark with uh bart quan's name and he
goes fight me [ __ ] he just says that's
a random like ufc fighters i just get
inspired by people's inspires i just
write random things on all kinds of
stuff [ __ ] truck pages everything
what do you write on truck pages yeah oh
that's a stick truck
that's remember when he was talking to
the game the rapper oh yeah what'd you
say to the game what do you mean when
you don't remember this you were dming
the game remember you asked
our friend used to cook for him you know
he had a bunch of jk shirts the game
what yeah because our friend used to
cook for him and like do all he was like
his like personal fitness and and food
dude nutritionist nutritionist or
whatever he would [ __ ] cook food and
then [ __ ] go out and wait like lift
weights with them and then um so i gave
him a stack of t-shirts just give to his
friends and [ __ ] and then one day he
sends me a picture of game at the at the
[ __ ] well you know that trail that that
everyone goes running canyon runyon
canyon
and then they have jk shirts on that's
so funny oh yeah he's on the patreon
you gotta have that framed in the office
the game posted something about like um
i'll jump on any rapper's verse or
whatever just like let me know uh how
much and whatever so that's when you dm
uh just i'll rap on anybody's song right
so i wrote like how much a verse
and then he goes really depends on what
you can afford tell me that number and
i'll hit you back
i'm all right how do you make his
message all covered in fine
i don't know what would you pay for what
would you guys pay
what would you pay for a for a verse
from game depends on what kind of song
i'm trying to make a love song no i
don't west coast lover i would want to
make a song about chinese food and then
have them wrap up
back in the day you guys should have
like you know like you guys just do like
songs and stuff yeah you should have had
him like hop like it should have been a
funny song had him hop on do the hardest
verse for like this random time and then
you guys come back and do like the call
just mad
seriously he's killing people in the
background and stuff and you guys come
back and do the normal like the funny
stuff we should have talked about
instant noodles or something yeah yeah
and he comes back talking about like
he's smoking your mom
[Laughter]
or
or we have them do the first verse and
as soon as we come and we go i disagree
with counterpoint wait i can't afford
everything you just nullify his work
you have to go to school you have to be
a good boy
look that would have been i disagree
well it sounds like he's in already and
you kind of ghosted it you didn't come
back with a counter offer i don't know i
didn't know he was gonna the hard part
is do you think he'd do it
do you think he'd do it for 10k no hell
no really because he could just record
the acapella at home and then he could
just send it over
it's the game dude i think he might do
it for like i think he'll he'll think
about it maybe he'll send you one he
wrote for someone else that he didn't
use
all right it's all like all the
references are outdated and [ __ ]
sorry for 2014.
make him do a verse on jk news
oh i should have i have a mop on for one
article like it's so rare oh yeah that
that's what it is yeah would he even
show up in person that's the question
because he might just he might just send
us a verse like like an acapella and we
have to put it in i like the idea that
the game shows up alone we should just
get a beat like just get someone to make
a beat and then just send it to him be
like hey game what you think and then
just see he's gonna be like you know
he's not flowing you know
he's like hey what do you think you can
rap on this what do you think and then
you talk price later you know that's how
you got to chuck first oh like this song
is so good maybe he'll give us a
discount i get a really good beat
because you might you because he's
already interested he already responded
he might fall in love with this so much
it gives me a price i can't afford and
now he gets to keep it now
that's true yeah yeah he's gonna just
steal the beat yeah yeah yeah yeah they
do have experience being countered by uh
certain pitches yeah
this is my song now i'm like oh man
he just bullies you my friend told me
that like they went to lunch with some
jewelers because these guys were trying
to sell them like all this [ __ ] bling
and [ __ ] right and he goes by the end of
the the of the lunch they ended up
giving him like mad pieces of jewelry
for free
their intention was going in there to
buy this [ __ ] and sell it to him
and then game talked a good [ __ ] game
and apparently at the end he was just
like yeah we're gonna help boost your
business this and that i got all these
other rappers i can introduce you to and
this and that and he ended up just
getting all this free jewelry wow
i got scammed out of uh that's why he's
called the game a verse before yeah yeah
because when i'm back in arizona when i
was rapping i did a song with this guy
named big nuke who was part of brick
squad um
monopoly yeah big deal it was like waka
flaka's you know thing and so i i did
one verse for him it was 500 bucks he
did a verse on one of my songs that i
had and then i hit him up again to do
like another one because it did well and
he's like oh i sent him 500 he's like
hey yo if you can send me another 200
i'll get waka on it he's here in the
studio with me right now for 200 bucks
that's a deal why wouldn't you jump at
that
i was like yeah and i was like [ __ ]
it's like all right cool and i don't
really have money it was like all right
cool so i sent him another 200 and i had
to go do those money order things you
know i had to go to the store
he [ __ ] indian scam director
that's how we did it the first time and
it went through so i was like all right
whatever that's like pre-vemo huh yeah
yeah thank god
2014 and then so i pay him the 200 and
then he sends me a text like an hour
later yo walk tripping my bad bro it's
going to be another 200. that's like wow
and i was just like no i was like [ __ ]
that i was like nah you just rap on the
song
and then he does he give you me never
wow
weird big nuke if you're watching my man
hey you all you owe alex seven hundred
dollars at least 200 back at least i
can't believe he there was only that
much to get him on a verse well he was
like a small artist but he was we liked
him because his [ __ ] was good you guys
didn't just trade like you know i'll be
on your your song you'd be on my song
you guys nah cuz he had like a name
today's video is brought to you by
upstart it can be hard to see the light
at the end of the tunnel when you have
high interest debt and sometimes it can
be even harder to ask for help that's
where upstart comes in upstart powered
personal loans can help you pay down
high interest debt all online and simple
and easy to understand payment terms
upstart has helped over 1.8 million
customers on their path to financial
freedom wow whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
upstart can help you get one fixed
monthly payment with a clear payoff date
upstart knows you're more than just your
credit score so rather than looking at
your credit score alone upstart's model
considers other factors like your income
employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate in minutes for
loans between 1 000 to 50 000
without impacting your credit score you
can even receive your funds as fast as
one business day after accepting your
loan don't wait and check your rate
today at upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com off
the record to check your rate today and
don't forget to use our url to let them
know that we sent you loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com off the wrecker
i mean big nuke is the name yeah what's
big new doing now probably in jail or do
you think we can find those yeah
yeah that's true i don't know he's never
been a guest on jk news so you know i
kind of feel like he groupied you you
know like you'll be like i'll let you
meet waka if you suck my dick up and
then you suck the living [ __ ] out of his
dick you didn't get nothing you didn't
even get to meet waka you got a groupie
by the [ __ ] groupie dude you got duke
that's true then he came back and was
like if you saw my homies dick i could
get walk on the track
i almost did it
it almost sucked so imagine though if i
would have walked on this you almost
sucked the whole entourage and you
didn't even get to meet walker
so you just lost
a dollar
700 and he never oh you mean nothing
ever came no he never he never sent me
the verse oh that's like eight thousand
dollars dude yeah that could what if he
just got lazy
or he went to jail or something they're
they're all hood like gangster
[ __ ] because maybe he's
honorable and then what if they were
really having an argument and it's all
on like true like he was like walker's
like i can't believe you just [ __ ]
charge 200 bucks you need at least 400
for that [ __ ] goes come on man he
already sent the money he goes no i'm
not gonna do it it goes fine all right
we need 200 bucks more no no
[ __ ] and then he didn't know what to do
completely innocent situation
that was a complete truth [ __ ] the
cop just kicked down the door
fbi everybody [ __ ] freeze they're
like ah he's like i gotta do this verse
i can't i can't go to jail yet i gotta
do this verse he i owe a verse i can't
let my friend down yeah my boy's at
western union about to send the money
right there
i gotta be i'll stay dude it was really
like that like every time i went i had
to sit there call them be like yo what's
the number you have to like write down a
number get the rounding number on the
weight make sure that they got it you're
like all right cool so much work but how
do you know it was him how do you know
it wasn't an indian guy pretending to be
a part of the [ __ ] crew because
there's how do you know you never know
but it was the same number as the first
do you still have the song that you had
when you featured
yeah
the first song that we did the first
song that we did is an actual song and i
have that song if you want to keep
working i gotta connect i could get the
game on it
hey and his message has fire on it i
don't know if he knows big nuke but we
can we can ask
but if he gets on then i have to get on
to disagree right after
i get his picture that's that's when the
beat stops i disagree
yeah it changes yeah yeah in a
vietnamese accent
bart's gonna rap in a vietnamese accent
and he's gonna contradict everything the
game says
and he's going to be like a goody
two-shoes the whole way
don't be a gangster get a a plus
i think it's still worth uh trying to
find big nuke and then if he has
instagram page you should just send him
a dm and just be like hey man dude hey
you owe me 700.
you still got that verse at least
at least you don't got to pay me back
but you got to give me a verse you know
now you owe me a theory look up what
he's doing now
i kind of want to find out where this
guy
is i know see what he's doing i know on
youtube if you search big nuke we jug we
eat that was like his big music video
but that's not the one you were wrong
that's not the one i was on hey you know
what i also wanna know what's [ __ ] up
about the situation so i don't know if
like you guys remember like live
mixtapes or dat piff and stuff yeah yeah
yeah yeah that pivot's still around yeah
so
they brick squad monopoly had a mixtape
they usually they used to draw mix tapes
with uh like all their artists songs and
stuff
and this was literally like four years
ago so this was recent i was on live mix
up i haven't been around i was listening
to one and then the song started playing
and then i looked and it didn't even
give me any credit it just said that
song name by big nuke
but you were you even
no i'm on the verse and everything but i
got no credit i was like i don't think
so he doesn't go by nuke bizzle too does
he i don't believe so nuke bizzle that
guy got arrested oh okay
i don't know could be the same dude
his instagram isn't big nuke with a blue
check mark yeah do you know big nuke's
real name yeah does he have a vivo page
is it like arthur johnson
i don't know arthur wilson johnson
this is funny when you look at the
rapper's name it's hard to be a rapper
with your name arthur no they're from
atlanta
like hotlanta jurassic park dirt gang
was with what they used to call
themselves
but well i think your hypothesis about
big nuke being in jail might be true i
think it's true yeah if he doesn't have
an instagram there's a big nuke that's a
bigger nuke no that's not big now big
newcastle looks like an mma fighter like
little dreads and
uh little dread sounds like his friend a
little dry
big new little treads yeah little dread
was featured on your song yeah honestly
probably watch let me see big news
there's a lot of big nukes dude we can't
find him i guess he wasn't that big
right here
that's why it's 700 bucks a verse
200 bucks for waka that's you know you
would jump in i would have flopped on
that dude i would have [ __ ] up and
sent 200 bucks there too i would have
sent an extra 200. you're right because
i already sent five so i'm like oh 700
for reverse all right that sounds about
right this is big nuke right here oh
yeah i can't find that dude
does he have a perb that's a good that's
a good video yeah yeah there's too many
other big nukes that have popped up
since how did you wait how did you even
meet big nuke in the first place well no
it was just because like we listened to
waka flaka and like oh yeah all of his
artists and stuff so how did you get to
him because he was part of a group
called dirt gang
and he they had a couple songs and he
sounded sick so i mean like how did you
even contact oh i just
i think it was just instagram back in
then dirt gang that's like your guys's
rivals dirt gang they're the careful
boys versus the dirt
the dirt gang sounds like they could
beat us up dude they sound they sound
they say they won't beat us up but they
will shoot us yeah
i think they might beat us up we might
be the better fighters but we can't
fight those bullets that's not saying
that that's true we don't want to go to
jail i don't know how big newt got his
name either
imagine he actually has a news
he might be doing the most illegal crime
out of all of it
yeah like that's that's the one he
doesn't have any guns but he just has
more nukes
arguably worse because i'm the nuke plug
of atlanta yeah there's like weapons of
mass destruction threaten someone people
pull like a gun on you and then you just
pull out a button yeah yeah dude we're
all dying
[ __ ] i'll kill myself i'm crazy like
don't be a venice remember he had the
giant rocket yeah
he's like hey [ __ ] you he puts up he
runs off he's like
it's that old-school [ __ ] acme
detonator
menace to society right where he lifts
up the the back of the thing and he has
like the little the big-ass nuke dude
[Laughter]
you know like those dudes on the band
when they have the suspender keyboard
and [ __ ]
who has a straight up duke operating
table that he walks he has the briefcase
he types in your address he's like
briefcase man we have to put two keys
and [ __ ] twist it and hit the button
you guys are advanced dude i want to see
that [ __ ] in real life i wonder what it
really looks like like a nuke the new
button like it because in the movies
it's always like you gotta unlock it
five different ways right like what does
it really look like i think it is still
like analog like i don't think they let
it be on the internet
it's just a series yeah because the song
is hacked that [ __ ] and yeah
yeah i think i read something that
they're not letting it be on the
internet because of that that's like you
actually have to be pretty [ __ ] smart
of them not to do that yeah it's
actually just a big red button and like
a lock up case actually yeah like
[Laughter]
i like in cartoons like it's on the
president's desk like it's always
like you never know when he needs it
what if it was right next to this
[ __ ] speaker for the secretary and
[ __ ] and he [ __ ] hits it on accident
oh [ __ ]
and then still makes his announcement uh
there's tamales downstairs
i know i love the fact that it's that
easy to hit as if like no we want it
there in case you have an emotional
impulse yeah and you need to it doesn't
wear off
it's a flex though isn't it one thing
i've always wanted and i'm like man i
need to find someone that can do this is
you know the bookshelves where you go
like secret room oh yeah i've seen like
[ __ ] like that on instagram like in
people's houses now oh so it's doable
yeah i couldn't do that people would
call me out like you don't read i'm like
the robber just knows
don't check the books don't check the
books the key is any book yeah
you just need to have a [ __ ] closet
full of clothes and then one of the
covers oh that would be cool just like
take that [ __ ] and it opens it
up what do you guys have in the back
though i don't even know yeah right like
more clothes literally nothing just a
chair we're like i got the room
it rotates this is where i keep my
really good boots
or it's the other way around it's all
guns and when you take the gun off
but it's like sin is mightier than a
sword it's like all the manuals for the
guns though
you want to know how to use it though i
think if bart had one it would just be
like a blanket and just one pillow on
the floor just because this guy likes to
take naps i love him in the room back
there [ __ ] it's a nap room you never
wanted to make a panic room
you can't wait for someone to go to this
house dude i want a button that if
intruder comes i hit the button and they
keep them in the house
becomes your roommate
yeah yeah it's like a venus flytrap it
goes to like squatter laws and the cops
like we can't take him man he's your
roommate now
dude i wonder if that's a if that's an
um a valid thing to do like if a robber
is breaking your house and the cops come
and the robber just goes nah man i live
here too
and the cops are like oh then we can't
do nothing yeah like what's the fine
print right like what's the fine print
on it or you can claim kidnapping like
they kidnapped me yeah he brought me
here against my will there was a guy who
um tried to rob a hairdresser in russia
we did a jk news about this guy and that
lady's like [ __ ] no and she beat his ass
up and then kept him inside the back
room and basically raped his ass
oh i remember that so gangster yeah who
is this woman i don't know i would give
her another gangsta
raped his ass or raped his ass i don't
know which way probably both that's
russia some combo both it just sounded
like some gangster some russian ass laws
is that in the russian law they're like
if you catch them you can rape them yeah
until we get there it's all up to you if
they try to rob you
fair game
i feel like texas is pretty close
probably i feel like if you if someone
broke onto your property and you felt
threatened i feel like you can tie them
up
and then wait until people come dude
i can't torture them but i'm pretty sure
you could tie them up and do stuff like
that yeah
yeah
i feel like you should be able to like
hold them down tie them up and then make
out with them make out with them do
their hair paint their nails yeah that's
hog tying right there if i got tied up
i'd be so embarrassed
getting tied up especially like belly
down imagine you break into somebody's
house and then you're just getting
manhandled and tied up
you're just like damn this went south so
quick no i'm not a gangster
i should go back to school dude because
whenever people get caught they start
like begging like please like let me go
please please please please i would skip
straight to acceptance dude i'd skip all
the stages of grief and just go straight
to me there was one viral video of i
think it was like a cash check place and
a guy comes in
and the ladies behind the glass were
like oh this motherfucker's going to rob
this so they all slowly snuck out and
they locked them into oh i've seen that
he's like [ __ ] he's like
he starts shooting the [ __ ] dance
yeah and almost for a second you kind of
feel bad for him because he's like [ __ ]
he's like realizing that he's regret
yeah yeah yeah and but then he gets
arrested you [ __ ] up dude yeah you
can't be robbing people instant karma
baby unless you're in cali then it's
okay to appoint
it's all okay you could rob people and
then get away with like a guy yeah just
watch that uh 900 limit
[Laughter]
they're stealing money and then they're
like here take 200 bucks back
[Music]
this